listen to Mitch McConnell Mitch  McConnell he's part of the swamp really  I mean just watch this and tell me that  this is how you feel providing  assistance for  ukrainians to defeat the Russians that's  the number one priority for the United  States right now according to most  Republicans that's sort of how we see  the  challenges confronting the country at  the moment giving more money to Ukraine  is not in my top 20. nobody wants to do  this except you evil sucking swamp  creatures you're the only people who  want to do this it is not the top of  anyone's mind how about the economy how  about the Border how about Free Speech  we could go through a whole bunch of  stuff here  he's just awful